new at 11 members of the UNLV football
team mourning the loss of a teammate
tonight the university confirming
linebacker Ryan Keeler passed away
earlier today Keeler only 20 years old
earned academic all-mountain West honors
his first year with the program after
transferring from Rutgers University new
head coach Barry Odom saying he got to
know Keeler over the last couple of
months saying quote he already stood out
to our coaching staff as an incredible
person student and teammate our
condolences and prayers go to Ryan's
family as we grieve along with them over
this tremendous loss no cause of death
has been announced at this time